[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
ladies and gentlemen i've been uh
informed that you have a verdict a
verdict is handed down for the convicted
daytona beach serial killer and a
spotlight shown on the mental health
issues of convicted church shooter dylan
roof while his legal team has filed a
petition with scotus plus this is not
the outcome
that we and so many
had hoped and prayed for over the last
year the adoptive parents of oren and
orson west now charged with their
murders but first we the jury found the
defendant brad hankinson we are live in
louisville kentucky just hours after a
verdict is handed down in the trial of
ex-officer brett hankinson law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm imran ansari in for brian buckmeyer
who is in kentucky covering the death of
brianna taylor case here with me in new
york is co-host terry austin
a verdict is handed down in the case of
ex-louisville officer brett hankinson
charged in connection to the death of
brianna taylor
hankinson was not charged in taylor's
death but instead faced charges of
wanton endangerment for firing shots
into taylor's apartment that went
through the wall in the neighboring unit
hankinson was one of three officers
involved in a no knock drug raid
performed on taylor's apartment in march
of 2020 believing the officers were
intruders taylor's boyfriend kenneth
walker fired at them the officers shot
back and taylor was killed in that
crossfire former officer john mattingly
was also shot
officials say ex-officer miles cosgrove
fired the deadly rounds that killed
taylor
on thursday defense attorney stu
matthews presented the defense's closing
arguments saying hankinson acted to save
the lives of fellow officers
brett hankerson did not know there was
an apartment behind brianna taylor's
that his bullets could go into and i
would submit that even if he had
he did what he thought he had to do in
that instant
and that's
that's what you have to be cognizant of
is this all happened in such a short
span ladies and gentlemen the bottom
line is
that through all this the the
commonwealth is trying to say that
because brett hankinson took the actions
he took he's a criminal and he deserves
to be in prison
i submit that brett hankinson's the
farthest thing from that you heard
how he reacted to try to save his
brother officers
you heard everything he did police
related activities that he engaged in
after
after the shooting was over
assistant attorney general barbara
whaley countered saying enough evidence
was presented to convict the former
officer
this case is about the actions of brett
hankerson
when he shot
into the side of that building
in the opposite direction
from those
who were
in the line of fire coming out of the
apartment the evidence that you've seen
from the commonwealth
and
the defendant's testimony
is
that is guilty under this law of wanton
endangerment
of cody
chelsea
and five-year-old satan
whose head was on the pillow right in
the corner of that bedroom
closest to where the bullets were flying
through
he
is who this case is about
then after only three hours of
deliberation jurors reached a verdict
we the jury found the defendant brad
hankinson not guilty of wanton
endangerment in the first degree under
instruction number four as that applies
to cody etherton as to chelsea nepper
napper we the jury find the defendant
brett hankerson not guilty of wanton
endangerment as to verdict form number
three wanton endangerment first degree
as to zayd and f we the jury find the
defendant brett hankinson not guilty of
wanton endangerment
you heard it there not guilty on all
charges our own brian buckmeyer was
inside the courtroom as that verdict was
read he joins us now live from
louisville kentucky brian
yeah imran as you said not guilty on all
counts for wants and endangerment as it
applies to all of the three alleged
victims in this case now during the
reading of the verdict you could hear a
pin drop you have the family of both
kenneth walker as well as the family of
brianna taylor in the room no outburst
no kind of screaming when it came down
to that not guilty verdict however as
the families walked out you can see
distress uh some anger and even some
sorrow especially in the faces of the
palmer family uh that being tamika
palmer the mother of brianna taylor now
i got to speak with brett hankinson's
defense attorneys just hours after the
verdict sorry minutes after the verdict
where they talked about this being the
first day of the rest of brett
hankinson's life and that he's looking
forward to being
not convicted of these charges and going
on in his life
well brian that's uh great reporting and
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and also trial attorney bernarda
villalona bernarda i want to start with
you with the basics do you think the
jurors reached the correct verdict here
so in regards to brett hankinson and
what he was charged with i believe that
the jury did reach the correct verdict
in this case and i called it from day
one to an opening statement i didn't
believe that the prosecution will be
able to prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that brett hankinson took an
unsubstantial and constantly disregarded
and unsubstantial unjustifiable risk
because when you think about it he
responded like anyone would respond
shouts were being fired and he returned
shots in order to protect his fellow
officers yes it's the answer that we
don't like but it's the one according to
the facts that were presented and the
prosecution had been the burden of proof
it is the correct verdict in the end he
wasn't charged for anything having to
deal with brianna taylor that issue lies
with the attorney general daniel cameron
who decided not to bring those charges
to the grand jury to decide
yeah terry does the
fall does this verdict does it fall back
do you think on the prosecution's
closing arguments
where do you think that the prosecution
fell short in not getting this
conviction
actually i agree with bernard i think
the prosecution fell short in the very
beginning throughout this trial she
failed to tell a story she mentioned
during her closing that hankinson shot
in revenge for shooting his fellow
officer but there was never any evidence
about that at all and frankly the other
police officers simply didn't support
that theory hankinson himself said he
was defending his fellow officers and by
the way they shot into neighboring
apartments as well so
i think that all in all she failed and
she did not prove her case and that's
why we got the verdict we did
yeah and brian you were in the courtroom
for it all how did the jurors react to
those closing arguments we
saw so the jurors were pretty stoic i
thought that they were listening i agree
with bernard and terry up until closing
arguments i didn't really think the
prosecution was carrying their burden i
thought they got a little bit closer to
that in summation mainly because of the
organizational skills of the prosecutor
and how the jury was being attentive but
i think it was far little far too late
and that's why we got the verdict we got
even though the defense's closing
arguments was only 24 minutes because
per stu matthew's own words the rulings
prior to that closing arguments
eviscerated his closing but it seems to
be enough for the jury
and the jury has spoken not guilty on
all three counts thank you brian
still ahead on the law and crime daily
attorneys for convicted killer dylan
roof take a petition all the way to the
supreme court but first years after two
young california boys go missing their
adoptive parents are charged with murder
our anjanette levy is live with the
latest details in that case
[Music]
a sad ending to the search for two
little boys in california reported
missing 14 months ago the district
attorney in bakersfield california says
oren and orson west are dead but their
bodies have not been found lawn crimes
angenette levy is here with more
imran a grand jury has indicted orrin
and orson west adoptive parents on
charges of felony child abuse and second
degree murder and sadly the kern county
district attorney says that those boys
were actually killed three months before
their parents reported them missing in
december of 2020. now oren and orson's
were reported missing by those parents
triselle and jacqueline west and police
said the west initially told them the
boys wandered away from their backyard
in cal city california and walked into
the desert quite possibly shortly
thereafter the bakersfield police
department became involved in the
investigation
that investigation and the investigation
spanned 14 months and included the
execution of more than 40 search
warrants the district attorney said she
can prove that the brothers are dead
one of the questions that i'm sure you
would like to know is have the bodies of
warren and orderson been found and the
answer to that is no
they have not been found however i would
like to emphasize
that the fact that law enforcement have
not found their bodies does not preclude
a murder prosecution
as a matter of fact there have been
many hundreds of what we call nobody
homicides prosecuted across the united
states successfully and even nobody
homicides have resulted in murder
convictions in kern county
now because this case was indicted by a
grand jury many of the details about the
investigation and the allegations are
not being made public at this time and
the d.a will not say why the west were
charged with second-degree murder
rather than first degree murder
jacqueline and triselle west appeared in
court in bakersfield california on
thursday they were ordered held without
bail and both pleaded not guilty imran
thank you angenet now let's bring back
terry and bernarda for more legal
analysis terry i'm going to start with
you
if the bodies of the children have not
been found how do you think the
authorities are going to be able to
determine when these deaths occurred
well one of the things the d.a said is
that it's a combination of this direct
and circumstantial evidence that they
have they had 50 witnesses at this grand
jury proceeding and apparently they know
enough to know that these two children
are dead so maybe they saw a witness who
said that the boys were being carried
out or maybe there was a video that
showed some packages being carried that
looked like it could have been the
bodies they could even have audio
recordings where one of them is
admitting that there was some sort of
fight with the children and perhaps that
has been taped and they can use that so
i think there is a lot of evidence
pointing to the death particularly
because we know that they have a timing
of it and they don't want to show their
cards right now they want to keep all of
that secret so they can use it when it
comes time for the trial and you know
they could even have dna evidence of
blood even if they don't have those
bodies
yeah bernardo i want to ask you your
former homicide prosecutor what does it
mean that the adoptive parents
jacqueline and triselle west were
indicted by a grand jury
this is such a tragic case unfortunately
of course what happened is that a grand
jury determined that based on the
evidence that was presented by the
prosecutor that there was sufficient
evidence to one determine that these
parents these two individuals were the
ones that were responsible for the death
of these two kids but also there's
probable cause to believe that they also
were the ones who actually committed
this homicide so it's not only that
they're dead but that these parents were
the ones who committed this homicide
this is not anything out of the ordinary
with a grand jury proceeding you had 16
individuals at least that heard the
testimony and made that determination
it's going to be a long while before we
hear what exactly was presented because
grand jury proceedings are sealed
yeah and anjanette has kern county
prosecuted
nobody cases in the past
yeah imran it's actually pretty
interesting uh cynthia zimmer during
that press conference said as you heard
that there have been these nobody
prosecutions across the country that
have been successful and she said
actually in kern county they've had two
in the recent past nobody homicides
where
a conviction
was obtained on those cases she said
there could have been more in that
county she just doesn't recall them or
wasn't around back then
no matter what it's a real tragedy thank
you
coming up on law and crime daily
convicted killer robert hayes learns his
sentence in a florida courtroom plus
mental health issues take center stage
in the case of convicted south carolina
church shooter dylan roof what petition
the supreme court may soon discuss
[Music]
welcome back the attorneys for the
convicted south carolina church shooter
dylann roof turned to the supreme court
for guidance on mental health issues
with a defendant this all stems from
roof's 2017 death penalty sentencing
during which roof fired his legal team
and opted to represent himself
roof's current appellate attorneys say
this measure successfully prevented
federal jurors from hearing evidence on
his mental health issues in a petition
attorneys said roof was quote under the
delusion that he would be rescued from
prison by white nationalists but only
bizarrely if he kept his mental
impairments out of public record
attorneys have now petitioned scotus
asking who gets the final say when a
capital defendant and their attorneys
disagree on whether to present evidence
that they are mentally ill in 2017 roof
became the first person in the united
states to receive the death penalty for
conviction of a federal hate crime so
far all appeals to overturn that
sentence have been rejected in 2015 roof
opened fire on a charleston south
carolina church killing nine
african-american people
all right let's bring in bernard and
terry to break this down bernardo i'll
start with you
what factors do the supreme court have
to take into account here what sort of
decision could we end up seeing
so we're going to see a whole bunch of
conflicting issues in this case because
you are guaranteed under the
constitution the right to effective
representation legal representation so
if that is the case the attorneys are
acting in the best interest of the
client in order to give them effective
representation especially if they
believe a defense that they're going
with can mitigate their exposure and
that is what is going on in this case
the question is going to be in the
court's gonna have to decide who should
we believe who should actually make such
a crucial decision the person who
doesn't have a law degree the client but
who has so much to lose or the person
with a law degree and can apply that
effective representation and see how
it's going to affect the rest of the
country this decision
yeah and terry dylan roof was found
competent to stand trial do you think
that was the correct decision
actually i do think it was the correct
decision here he seems perfectly
competent that simply means that you're
able to understand those proceedings and
that you can take part in your defense
and clearly he is taking part in his
defense it's very different from whether
or not you can assert mental illness
meaning you didn't know the difference
between right and wrong here the
competency means he understands these
proceedings one of the things i was
thinking about is if he has so far
stated he has no remorse for these
killings and he has said that why not
just plead not guilty so it's
interesting he understands what's going
on and yet he still has pleaded not
guilty i don't understand why he doesn't
plead guilty rather
yeah we'll all be waiting to see how
scotus rules on this very interesting
and we'll bring it to you
when we come back we head to florida for
the final chapter in the penalty phase
for robert hayes the convicted killer
learns his fate after a jury deliberates
for hours to decide a sentence
[Music]
welcome back to law on crime daily a
convicted serial killer will spend the
rest of his life behind bars as a
florida jury recommends a life sentence
the jury's ruling came late wednesday
night
sparing robert hayes from the death
penalty
mr hayes the jury having found you
guilty of first-degree murder as a count
one in the indictment i judge you guilty
sends you to life imprisonment without
the possibility of parole in count two
adjudicate you guilty sends you to life
imprisonment without the possibility of
parole and count three adjudicate you
guilty impose a life
in prison without the possibility of
parole each sentence shall run
consecutive to one another
last week a jury convicted hayes of
killing three women laquetta gunther
julie green and iwana patton in the
daytona beach area back in 2005 and
2006.
authorities say the three women were sex
workers
ten years later a fourth woman was
killed in west palm beach during that
investigation hayes dna was linked to
the three daytona beach murders
throughout the trial the state's case
leaned on that dna evidence meanwhile
the defense argued hayes dna was found
because he had sexual encounters with
the women before they were killed hayes
is also charged in that fourth murder in
west palm beach he will go to trial for
that case at a later date
all right let's bring in bernard and
terry bernard i'm going to start with
you hayes avoided the death penalty here
but he's set to stand trial for a fourth
murder could a second jury be as
forgiving
no i don't think so we're dealing with a
different group of people a different
set of jurors and those jurors will
probably not be forgiven for his actions
the sad part about is that i don't
believe they will know about this
conviction of these three women that
women that he got convicted for for
killing so we'll just have to wait and
see
yeah terry the judge decided that the
life sentences should run consecutively
why do you think he decided consecutive
sentences instead of concurrent
sentences
well listen and ron the judge has the
discretion to decide whether or not it's
concurrent or whether it's consecutive
obviously concurrent meaning all at the
same time consecutive one after the
other and what he's doing here is he's
looking at these aggravating and
mitigating factors to make that
determination and clearly since he said
consecutive it means that he's thinking
to himself these aggravating factors
were very serious and there were three
murders here in bernard's right they
probably won't hear that because of
evidentiary rules making it more
prejudicial than probative but we know
here there were multiple murders and
that is one of the main aggravating
factors and the judge is probably also
thinking about the fact that this was
cold calculated and premeditated what
they call ccp and he's thinking to
himself should i run this consecutive or
concurrent and he definitely decided
this should be consecutive when you
think about it at the end of the day
it's life without parole
physically it's not going to make a
difference because he runs it
consecutive or concurrent it's a life
sentence so he's just sending a message
yeah he will be behind bars we know that
and uh thank you for joining us here at
law and crime daily we will see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you